My first book
was about a group of Soviet
artists and how their lives changed
during glasnost. And the week it was published my
mother died.
And it was
a terrible, terrible time for me. And I felt as
though words which I had always counted
on had abandoned me. I couldn't write. I could
barely talk. None of it seemed to have any purpose or
any
value. And six weeks later I decided I had to get
away from home. And I thought I should go to some place
that wasn't about my
Mother. And I decided I would go to Moscow and see the artists
I'd been spending so much time with the previous few years. And I got there and
for the first five days it was a kind of place
of recovery. It was a place of feeling
apart from that great sorrow at least a little bit. And on the sixth day
I was asleep in a squat on the outskirts of Moscow that I shared
with all of these
artists, and my phone
rang. And I answered it. And it was a
rather melodramatic photographer I knew, who said:
Andrew,
Gorbachev has been kidnapped. And I think we
will have civil war, so I cannot have dinner with you
tonight. And I said, Vika
Ivleva, how many times have I told you never to call me
before eleven
am. I went back to bed. They've been so much
intrigue in the Soviet system, none of it seemed very significant. And when I got up and went downstairs
some of the other artists who were living in the squat were there. The artists at that time
were mostly doing work that was highly ironic. It was work
full of strange in hidden meanings. And as an installation project two of them had
done something that included a bed on which the
bed cover was a gigantic ten-foot Russian flag.
The Russian flag was still quite a radical symbol in those Soviet days.
And so when I went downstairs Kostya Zvezdochetov was sitting wrapped up in the
big Russian flag. And I said, "I had the strangest call
from Vika Ivleva this morning. She called and said that Gorbachev had been
kidnapped." And Larisa Zvezdochetova said, "That's strange, someone called me
me today and said they'd seen tanks in the south of
Moscow." And I said, "That's odd." And someone said: "Let's
turn on the television and see what's
happening." So we turned on the
television. Everyone had vodka in Russia or coffee, or some mix of the two.
And we went from channel to channel. And on every channel on the television there were
Tchaikovsky ballets.
And Larisa said, "OK." She said, "I was not so frightened
about Gorbachev kidnapped. I was not so alarmed
about tanks and south Moscow but I am terrified by these Tchaikovsky ballets.
copy balance.
This is what they did, she explained. This is what they did when Stalin died. This is
what they did when Brezhnev was removed from power. This is what they do.
When the news is so momentous that there is nothing to say.
So we all thought we should try to find out what was happening. And we made a few calls and we decided
A lot seem to be happening around the Russian parliament building. And so we went
down there on the Metro. And we got out at the station Barrikadnaya. Called
Barrikadnaya because that's where the barricades
were built in the original 1917 revolution. And when we
got there, as we were leaving, there was the woman who sweeps the
station and there were always these women. Hundreds of thousands of people pouring through and they were sweeping
the dust and they never said anything and they were bent over.
And we got to this station and she was standing erect and pointing with the broom and saying,
"Go to the demonstration. Go at once to the demonstration" to
everyone who came
out. So we went to the demonstration.
And as we went we had to pick our way in between construction debris because at that point
everything in Moscow was under construction and none of it was ever finished. And in general it was
a terrible nuisance.
But in this instance, it turned out to be a great thing because as we got closer, we saw
that people were dragging things from these construction sites to build barricades
around the Russian parliament
building. And there was a woman, a rather elegant woman in high heels who is standing just
near the edge of the barricade and asking, "Excuse me, but do you know how
to operate a bulldozer?"
[laughter]
We helped with the building of the barricades. There was someone who had managed to jumpstart a crane
who had clearly, never before used a crane.
He would pick things up and get them up into the air. And they would
teeter there and then they would go down someplace else.
There was a woman, a sort of big Soviet Russian woman who was standing there
and trying to direct the whole thing and pointing where the crane should go and telling people where to drag things.
And yelling at the top of her lungs.
And at that time, in the Soviet Union, it was quite trendy
to have clothing with Western writing on it and people often had it but didn't
know what their clothes said. And she was wearing a T-shirt
that said "I'd rather be playing tennis." We
decided
We decided to go back down to the Parliament that night with a whole group.
We'd called all our friends, there were thirty or maybe forty of us. And someone said, but there are so
many people down there what if we get separated? And Kostya and Andrusha said,
"We'll take the big flag bedspread. We'll nail it to a pole. And
we'll have it and if we get separated, we can meet at the flag," which we all
thought was a good idea.
So we went down there. And we helped a little more with building the
barricades and, just as we were getting ready to go back home, a woman
to us and she said, "We have a giant helium balloon. We're blowing it up right now.
now. We're blowing it up because we want to show where we are. And we want to
the flag
so that everyone knows we're here. And you have the biggest Russian flag
I have ever seen." She said,
She said, "Will you give us your flag so that we can fly it over the parliament building?"
And Andrusha said, "Kostya?" and Kostya said,
"OK." So we left the flag.
Day Two.
We went down again. By now the barricades were fully built. There were people milling around.
Across the street from the barricades were
the tanks that had pulled up during the night and in the early part of the morning. And there were soldiers,
soldiers, very young soldiers on the tanks. And we went over to talk
We asked them where they came from and whether they'd been to Moscow before.
And how long they'd been in the military. And then
the artists would say, "If you
"If you need to fire tonight; if you're told to fire on the demonstration,
it's us. That's who you'd
be shooting at. It's us.
And if you decide not to do it, and you want to come over, we'll find you a place to
live and we'll protect you." And we gave them bread and chocolate
and sausages.
And then we went back to where everyone was milling around outside the parliament,
demonstrating, though no one knew quite what it was they were demonstrating for.
Someone had to use the loo and someone pointed out that a musicologist
I knew, Tanya ?Degenco?, had an apartment which looked right
over the Russian parliament building and, which was in fact inside the barricades.
And so we went up to Tanya's apartment and she said, "I did
not imagine that my apartment would become the toilet of the resistance.
But if this is how I can help,
I'm all for it."
Someone pointed out that I had a Western passport and I could check into an international hotel.
And if I did so, I could maybe get some other kind of news. And
I thought I'd try it. So I went to a Western hotel and I, in fact, could
get CNN. And I watched for a little while and the announcer said,
"Unbeknownst to the protesters gathered outside the Russian parliament building, there are
troops massing to the north of Moscow who seem to be headed in their direction." So
I picked up the phone and I called Tanya ?Degenko? and I said, "Unbeknownst
to the protesters outside the parliament building,
there are troops massing to the north of Moscow who appear to be mobilizing in
the direction of the parliament." And Tanya said, "Hold on a
minute," and then I heard this incredible, loud
bellowing sound. I couldn't figure out what it was. And she came back and
she picked up the phone and I said "Tanya, what was that?" And she said
"Now they know."
That night, we were outside
the building, talking to all the other people who were there. The rest
of the intelligentsia and everyone else who'd gathered.
And we heard the barricade being pulled apart. And we thought, oh no, the barricade is
being destroyed and we went running to see what was happening.
But it wasn't that the whole barricade was being destroyed. Boris Yeltsin was
riding in on his tank. To give his historic
speech about democracy and about the future of Russia. And he
came in and he was applauded. And everyone was thrilled. And he stood on the
parliament steps
And he began saying, "I speak to you today, under the
banner of Russia." And Kostya and Andrusha nudged each other
and said, "It's our banner.
It's our flag."
The third day.
The third day we got up and we decided to go up to Svetlanskaya near the American Embassy because
that was the place where three people had been killed the night before.
The only casualties of this unfolding drama. And
when we got there. It was such a Russian scene. There were flowers strewn on the ground. There
were old women crying. There were people talking about the nature of tragedy. And we were all standing
around and, suddenly,
a young man came running up. He had a tweed cap clutched in his hand
and wire-rimmed glasses and he looked like a 1917 revolutionary. Or like the
student in a Chekhov play.
And he said, "Hurry up. Come at once. There are tanks approaching the outer barricade. We have to go
defend the outer barricade."
Well, there had been tanks endlessly approaching and they had always just parked across the street. And so we walked
up to the outer barricade quite far away, in fact, from the parliament building. And we arranged
ourselves in front of it holding hands.
And two minutes later a column of tanks rolled up.
And they stopped about three feet away from us.
And it was still the Cold War. And I had grown up thinking that there was nothing
more frightening in the world
than a Soviet tank coming up to you. And the soldier
on the front tank said, "We have been given unconditional orders to destroy
this barricade. If you move out of the way...we don't need to hurt anyone but
if you won't move out of the way, we'll have no choice but to run you down.
And the artists I was with said,
"Give us just one minute.
Give us just a minute to tell you why we're here." And the soldier on the front
tank crossed his arms
and the artists launched into a description of what
freedom was. And they said you're very young. You don't remember the Stalin era.
Let me tell you what it was like.
It was terrible. They said you don't remember what it was like when Brezhnev ran things, but
that was terrible, too. And they said, "You say that you're just following orders,
but you're making a choice
to follow those orders and you could make another choice instead."
And they launched into a Jeffersonian panegyric to democracy, of a kind
that those of us who live in democracies mostly couldn't
master. And when they finished, we stood there sneezing, wet,
cold, bedraggled, and the soldier on the front tank
just stared at us for a full minute. And at the end of a minute he said,
"What you've said is true and we must bow to the will of the people.
If you'll clear us enough space to turn around, we'll go back and we'll leave
you your barricade.
And we all stepped aside.
And the tanks made U-turns, which is not so easy for a tank.
And they drove off the way that they had come.
And we all embraced one another.
And then, I had to go to the airport because my visa
expired that day. And I
got in a cab and I was on my way to the airport when
the news came on.
The putsch had failed. Yeltsin
was in charge. Russia was to be a democracy.
And I thought that language had come back for me. I thought I would be
able to write and talk again because what I had always hoped
but never believed to be true was that if you could only
speak clearly enough about important things, you could
change the world. And I thought
how revolutions occur because
of tiny acts
by many people. And when I got to Sherametyevo, I managed to get a phone
and I called my friends, and Kostya answered the phone, and I said,
"Is it true? Is it really true?" And he said,"Yes." And I could hear
the people dancing and singing in the background. And I said, "Kostya, do you
think we had anything to do with it?"
And he said, "Of course we did." He said, "We helped to build the barricades.
We stood outside that parliament building. We turned around that column
of tanks." And then
he paused, and he said, "But it was my flag."
Thank you.